critical race theory is basically saying
some are oppressor some are oppressed
what kind of a message is that sending
to these very young kids so so we
require all of that and remember there
was no critical race Theory being taught
to young kids our standards in terms of
the basic history with the College Board
was trying to do they were trying to
impose CRT they actually were trying to
impose in a black studies course queer
Theory they were trying to impose
intersectionality and they were trying
to impose effectively neo-marxism and so
the question is is that something you
want to do on your own time yeah yeah
you're free save neo-marxism for the
privacy of your bedroom please be to go
pursue that but for our taxpayers to be
supporting that type of indoctrination
that is not something that we want to do
now you might be hearing this and saying
David what the hell is Ron DeSantis
talking about here well he's talking
about the things that potential 2024
voters want to hear him talk about